what made you decide to come here it's a
really good question
lots of different answers I think the
most important is I was sat home one
evening and looking at the news and I
thought to myself
how could I not do something about this
how can I not go out there and help
especially seeing the war crimes being
committed on civilian populations I just
thought
I can't can't sit by and let this happen
it reminded me of stories that my
grandmother and grandfather taught me
about the first World War uh second
world war even in Britain you know
and I thought to myself
in this Century we're experiencing stuff
like this still and by a first world
country like Russia let's just
Criminal
but a lot of people I think feel very
deeply about it but they've taken up
volunteering or delivering Aid or
helping and raise money I mean coming
and putting yourself on the front line
is a whole different ball game isn't it
yeah for sure I think if you can do that
then it's valuable to do that because
there aren't many people I think that
would want to do that and of course most
people my age have a wife and kids to
worry about so being in that position I
I don't have to worry about what my wife
is thinking of me or my children are
thinking of me so I can just
do what I need to do and get hands on
right on the front line and
try and help in the best way I can and
what sort of action have you seen so far
probably the worst thing I saw we were a
stabilization point which used to be a
true children's hospital
um quite Far North
quite close to where we are now
be further west but um we had a Russian
artillery shell go off about 100 meters
from the hospital building blew out all
the windows
that was quite a stark realization of
how little of a dam the Russians give
about the ukrainians
did you feel like you came close to
getting hurt or injured yourself
it's difficult to explain that
I mean with artillery you're never going
to know until after you've been hit so
I always I always thought when I was a
kid if somebody you know if I ended up
in a war zone I'd seen it on the TV I
always thought that wow how do people
put up with that knowing that they might
get blown up any any second but when
you're actually there and it's peace and
quiet like this you just forget all
about it there's no point worrying about
what could be
there's a lot of talk about potential
war crimes being committed what have you
seen on the ground that either backs
that up or not I've seen Medics wounded
by Russian uh rifle rounds
I've heard countless Tales I've
personally never seen Medics shot at
myself in the short time I've been here
but I've heard countless stories from
2014 of Medics being shot at especially
by Russian Sharpshooters who seem to be
trained to shoot Medics first
I'm not sure about the average Russian
soldier but from what I've heard they
also will pick on medics
so what have you seen this time that
might show that they're targeting
civilians or ambulance workers or anyone
I've said he's a non-competent I've seen
bullet holes stricken all across our
ambulances at the HQ
um of Russian caliber
and you know the hospitals that we go to
that are just shattered windows and
sandbags all up there it's like nothing
I've ever seen before it's incredible
and what's the reaction been from the
fellow Ukrainian Fighters that you're
alongside to you yeah
they're they're really glad to have us
here in any way possible and
it never underestimate the value of just
being there and having our flag on your
arm because that means the world to them
because they know that we're sending
them weapons and we're sending them
Vehicles trying to help out passively as
much as we can but just being there
in person
it keeps their mind
at ease knowing that we're
the whole world stands with them